[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello my name is Francis I look like
this most places on the internet and I
work a bustle VP of engineering a puzzle
and so we are a Content site where
digital a digital media company and a
lot of people ask hey Francis how did
you everyone a puzzle like that would
say so fast and I know this one you know
we put everything in Redis and since
that's not a talk and it's usually
doesn't explain anything I did make this
talk and I call it we live in memory
because it's a really nice way to say we
use Redis and I'm gonna tell you about
how we use Amazon lambda and graph :
Redis to make a really fast API if you
want to follow along if you want to do
the links any of the open-source you can
get the talks on the side here and I
just to prove you know that we really do
have fast api's I see 70 milliseconds in
the title because that's the average but
most requests are in 24 milliseconds and
this is our API response rate and I love
it makes me so happy if you're a stats
nerd you'll notice the distribution
there is a quite perfect like
distribution and that bothers me too and
I don't know why so this talks gonna be
in three parts I'm gonna tell you what
bustled is doing I'm gonna tell you how
we're doing it and then I'm gonna say it
tell you how you can do it so where as I
said we're a digital media company right
so we have you know big websites only
show ads and you know we do all kind of
stuff we're one of the largest
publishers for millennial women right
I found out we're actually just really
big in general we're bigger than the
Washington Post and they make news and
we're also biggest bigger than like
Stack Exchange which is also really
weird because that in my head is just
one of the most massive
sites out there yeah and then also doing
research I found out that WebMD is a
digital media site we're bigger than
them but the fact there are digital
media site instead of maybe like I don't
know a medical site it makes makes me
really and we're growing right so we
keep adding these sites to our platform
and it means we just got to keep you
know being able to go faster and store
more data so what are our goals right we
want to have the best reader experience
right and we want to have the best
features so we can make the most
interesting compelling content you know
and there is not a software project out
there that doesn't have these same goals
I just want to be good right our
strategies to make this happen is we
want a very fast page load like we got
it we have ads to show you you know and
we want to make it really cheap to
change things and throw stuff away and
try out new ideas yeah before I go much
further I just want to say what Amazon
lambda is because it's really easy to
assume everybody knows that except you
it's functions as a service and what
does that even mean it means you get an
API in this case an Amazon HTTP API
alright that lets you execute your
JavaScript or a couple other languages
function remotely and lets you do it
with a consistent environment right so
you have guaranteed CPU guaranteed
memory and it doesn't care if you have
one running every second or a hundred
thousand running every second you know
you're guaranteed to have just as much
memory and CPU available to every
request and this makes scaling easier
right and we're using it because we were
able to take a whole bunch of app
servers that we had there to handle push
notifications and unpredictable traffic
and we're paying about 30km month and
now we're paying 3km up you know in
lambda and sometimes we have like 15 20
X or normal traffic for like two minutes
you know and that that's sucks well I
mean that's hard I should say it's
actually really amazing and so and over
the time since we've been we've been
building this platform for two years in
this incarnation or so and we've grown
about 10
in that amount and I haven't had to
worry about it it's still the same
functions doing the same stuff you know
it's got to make sure the database can
stay up to speed and you know I will
have to worry about it soon but but it's
bought us a lot so how does it actually
work right it works like this so when
you go and load this article and why
your kid wants to hear good night moon
again hits our CDN you know the CDN will
give you the rendered content or if
you're if you're already have the page
loaded and it's an API request to go
straight to the API we render everything
and react our API is handled by graph QL
and all the data comes from reddest
elasticsearch and you can sort of split
this up into a few layers the CDN layer
the rendering layer the API layer the
database layer and the CDN tries really
hard not to bother anyone else with
anything if you can serve your request
the CDN servers are much closer to where
you live you know they're all around the
world and I would rather everything to
be served out of the CDN I would rather
be 100% CDN served site but you know
there's a couple options you can use
especially if this stack right now we're
using fastly but I actually have one
more requirement I want out of my CDN is
that it should execute my functions this
is weird because a function execution
isn't exactly an HTTP request and but
it's close enough and it can give them
the same data and it should be a
question again
and so in this world where I don't
actually have any web servers I don't
want to have an upstream web server I
want to have you know the CDN do all the
work and so we accomplished this kind of
hacky we have API gateway which is
Amazon's web server for functions and
that executes sar lambda and then we
have fastly in front of it and fastly
gives us really fast cache invalidation
so when we update a post it's
it's a pushed out to follow the seed in
and 100 a minute usually under a second
to actually there's a near future where
maybe we use cloud flower workers or
they run
and have a v8 running in in the edge or
we use cloud front with their lambda at
the edge and have these executor
functions for us and that way we can
drop a whole hop about 10 or 15
milliseconds and you know we can we can
serve up stuff that much faster still a
little an experimentation but I think
this is something CD ends are going to
do from out of the box pretty soon their
rendering layer you know so this is a
function right and it gives us a status
and eight a body and headers and that's
everything you need for an HTTP response
you know it's got a couple of
responsibilities like this is the app of
bustled you know we're all client-side
apps and so it's got to do the
server-side rendering it's got to serve
up all the assets in a good way it's got
to you know be smart about the
components and the style shades and
break it all apart and so you know we
use react for our CMS's we use pre-act
because it's not much smaller for when
you go to bustled calm or raw / calm and
webpack makes everything possible we
even went pack the api we're happy with
how that works the api it's got a couple
of responsibilities it wants to take a
query and return some data you know and
then when you want to make a change yeah
take some input change the state and
then return some data and I have the
requirement that I want it to be strict
I want it to guarantee that when you ask
for a field do you know what you're
getting and you always get it and so we
use graph QL right because graph qo does
all these things we're able to we start
of like a dozen record services and so
whenever we wanted to make a request
we'd have to go and get it from one and
the other and the other and then try to
get them all back and then sometimes if
we didn't implement it right status
codes to be different you know err
errors would be a different shape we had
a lot of ifs in our in our response
handling to try to normalize it in fact
our front-end team did more data
normalization than our than our API team
and graph QL kind of gave us a single
place a single end point where we put
everything behind one thing and we wrap
all our third-party services and stuff
in this - it's helped a lot to have one
way to do things and the last player is
the database layer and you just want it
to store data safely right and you
wanted to retrieve data fast
and I wanted to retrieve data fast in a
consistent time because it doesn't help
me if I ask for a post and I get it and
and you know in under 70 milliseconds
and then I asked for it again later and
I get it in its second and a half like I
think that's broken yeah I want it to be
much much faster and so actually it can
even be slow if I know how fast it is
and in order to get this we use Redis as
our primary data star so if you don't
know Redis it's a data structure server
and it slow gives you things like hashes
and started sets and let you talk to it
over the network
let's do kind of operations on the stuff
remember a lot of people use this for
cash or maybe they put their sessions in
there because they could have sort of a
little JSON session in there and it's
really fast and gives it back but if
Redis dies you know if you if the
process exits all the data is gone and
you know what that's okay but just
because as good of that doesn't mean
it's actually not good as a database
it's got known persistence and most
people when they hear we use it they
they don't they don't know that because
why would you turn it on if it's
ephemeral data all right and so I tell
them and they don't believe me so I'm
gonna show you whenever I write comes in
it gets appended to this append-only
file which is how it is a lot of
databases have this kind of thing this
is the write log yeah and every second
we write this to disk so if the process
itself crashes which we haven't ever had
happen in four years but but it can it
we can just start it up again
I'll pick up where I left off that's
what everything back to memory and we're
fine we take that throw test3 but we
also take a full shot of memory which is
a little faster to load that's the Rd be
the Redis database file and we put that
desk three two and so we can restore
another machine we were start staging
every night off that data and you know
and we just have as much I haven't had
as good data retention in Postgres or
anything else I mean I mean and that's
that's the fault of the problem that's
the pole of our ops you know you can do
this pretty much any database of course
we have high availability there read
replicas in the primary so if it does if
it does exist it will readers won't
notice maybe we'll lose a couple of
requests well switches over that's
and this works very well for us you know
and you can you could do this with your
tool of choice this really this talk I
love Radisson I would love to actually
give an entire read of stock but but
this really could be any database
whatever your favorite is it will work
just fine so if we take our stock and
we've split it up into the layers you
know the CDN tries to do everything I
can not to bother anyone the rendering
gives you the rendered content you know
the API you know well forms and handles
all the changes to stay in the database
keeps everything safe we're gonna talk
about this part because part of the part
I know the most I'm not gonna talk about
elasticsearch but we use it you know for
search and we also related content and
some other nice things you know it's
great but in the end of the day Redis is
the primary so let's make an example I
recently became a dad and so all my
shoes are dad shoes you know and so I
heard it's actually hard to pull off dad
shoes and so I was like well let's check
it out and at the top of Google there's
a bustle article about dad shoes yeah
and it turns out the secret to dad shoes
is wearing a flowy skirt but if you look
at the data that goes into this post you
have what you would expect it's a JSON
blog right and we have sort of this tree
of data we have the site it's bustled it
has a post on the post field you know
and it has all the data for the post and
Escada the post has an author field that
has a user object it has a tags field
which has an array of tags and this
matches our graph QL querying real
closely we're asking for this in the
same shape and there's a little bit of
prescription here because we can ask for
it like this we get like this and we use
it like this but if we got it back you
know one request for each tag or even if
nested data if we got it back in a flat
format you know like with a JSON API or
something we would basically go and
build the shape again you know to give
it to our components so we've been very
happy with this you also get only the
fields you asked for so we can you know
in the API team just keep throwing stuff
in there for people to try out and most
using it they do we can get forget
fields and it pops up in their linter
and they say oh they'll use this field
anymore you know and it's kind of cool
if we remove all the data we end up with
this little tree right a graph perhaps
of the of the names of the you know the
types and their IDs and their
relationships right and if we squint and
we can make it kind of look like this
all right so this site has a post field
with the post and has the author field
of the user and the tags with the tags
if we want to describe this a little
more graph database II you know and they
the graph community uses the word
predicate to describe an edge I looked
it up on google i don't know why i'm
sorry but the predicates here side has
post and get a little more a little more
descriptive with them and so we can
store this in the database and like we
want to represent it and in order to do
that we built a graph database we call
it Gradius way after an old video game
and this is actually the name of our
whole API in the graph database the kind
of game hand in hand and this has
allowed us to grow with a relatively
small engineering team where were less
than 15 people you know over the past
couple years only we could have done it
without this so whenever I say what
graph database immediately people say oh
like neo4j right and exactly like neo4j
except it doesn't do anything to offer
to us your fridge a is amazing it's a
it's a very complicated actually I have
a hard time and this is a failing of
mine not it because they have wonderful
beautiful tools and I wish I had but
it's it's hard for me to understand it
does a lot and the queries can get super
complex right and the reason ours is
faster is because it's because we made
some trade-offs but I mean when people
say databases are faster right what do
they mean you know it's
I had a DBA should I work for and his
big analogy was trans art slow they have
one speed that people get it on up on
and off and the people are slow right
but if there were no people the trans
would be super fast databases are the
same they aren't slow the data going in
and out it's the queries that are slow
and they specially said this every
single time somebody complain the
databases for slow
but you can build a faster train and I
was the trade-off we made in fact we
traded query flexibility for speed and
we made it super difficult to make a
slow query you know and if you can't
have a slow query then everything is
fast right oh I think I should say yeah
we because it's not flexible because we
can't do these complex queries we
replicate to other databases elastic
search being one of them you know for
search but also to bigquery for you know
doing analytics and for you know you can
get a feed all the changes and so we're
playing of different databases you know
we have our DBMS is for reporting you
know but a rightist remains this for
sector so we don't love open source we
just had Ghost 2.0 got released various
ghost that uses mobile doc as a data
storage and we helped develop mobile doc
that's how we store all of our posts and
so we haven't been able to open source
Gradius because it's everything and it's
in no shape to be shared with other
people and so i started porting
everything to something I call Nemesis
DB Nemesis is the US arcade port of the
gradius game so I figured it was a good
name for it and it's really fast you
know as fast as iris already got
features I wish I could use and Gradius
and as soon as we get it to a certain
point I want to advertise cluster
support so we can get much bigger we
we're switching the whole company to it
it'll be a nice little migration by it's
not done however I use it completely in
this talk it does everything we showed
you here today and if this interests you
if you want to know how it works please
see me after please check it out and
open many issues and and like the fire
for me to finish this because I think
it'd be better for everybody so let's
make a graph QL server we're gonna go
over the tools we're gonna go over to
what a schema is we're gonna go over how
the resolvers work and I talked about
the loaders and this is our package JSON
dependencies are Apollo server
I love Apollo I wish I actually used
Apollo server for Gradius we started it
before it was ready I think but it's
totally ready now
and it's not that complex either and
that makes me happy it's hard to make
simple things and so the Apollo tools
and Apollo server stuff they've they've
been able to help make a more
straightforward to develop and I'm very
happy with it
and so our server file and this is what
you would use for developing on your own
machine reads like this you know you do
your requires and you get all your type
definitions it's just a file you read
into a string and then you start the
server and you say here that here is the
schema here are my results and don't
listen on a port there's not much more
to it if you have a lambda you know we
need to play to lambda it's the same
thing except they have a slightly
different server which knows how to
handle the lambda requests and instead
of listening on a port you tell lambda
hey this is the name of this is the
function you call for each request and
it handles handles the rest but what it
gives you is a lot so you have the it
can process graph you all queries but it
also gives you graphical which is a tool
that you can use to play with queries
all right and so I forgive me some
graphical czar white some are black some
are dark I don't know how easy this is
to read but this is a query on the left
on the data on the right and a big play
button in the middle and so you can get
auto completing queries where you can
hover and see which type it's supposed
to be and see the data it's gonna get
copy and paste this into your component
and use it and even better its
documenting because there is a schema
isn't just for the graph 12 server for
the client - and it's able to pull out
all the relationships so this is the
site which has a post which has an
author which is a user you know and you
can see what all the types are you know
you can see if they're gonna be null or
not and you can click around and and if
I broke descriptions which I didn't
you'd see them there too or deprecations
which I didn't you could see why we got
rid of stuff and I I firmly github
scratch qlae API is a wonderful shining
example of how you can do this right you
know we crimp stuff from them quite a
lot so the schema defines what the data
looks like and it doesn't care how it
works
so I have the state I have the posts and
the users and
but it all cares is what's the data it
kind of look like when you give it to
the API client doesn't care where it
actually comes from and so the only
thing required is the query right and
here we have a field called site and the
site has requires a name which is an
enum so you don't have to put in quotes
and it can only be specific things and
it returns the site object guaranteed
that's what the explanation point mean
this means not normal
and the site itself has two different
kinds of things it's got some data the
idea name right and that comes from our
database and then it's got this lookup
field post and post takes the required
path it's a string and it will try to
give you a post maybe give you a post
it's not no I rather it is knowable so
it doesn't know you know for sure that
there is opposed to that path and that's
okay neither do we but there's no
difference here between data and lookup
fields and and that comes later in the
resolvers post is another example you
have ID path title body those are all
data they're just strings and numbers
you know they could be objects but but
they're data and the authors is a lookup
for the user the tags does a lookup for
the tags and we guarantee to give you an
array and that array is guaranteed to
have zero or more tags in it so if there
is anything in the array it's going to
be a time but it doesn't have to be
anything and if you use the type
language or if your type script you know
you'll notice that there's no way you
can type the length of an array and
users and types are boring they're just
data no that's great so the resolvers
you don't need a resolver for everything
just for the lookups right and this is
where it kind of gets like this is where
the infinite power and variability you
know of how you million ways you can do
things sort of as a paralyzing force
when you're starting with crafty well
but it just needs to return full objects
of other things this is the you know you
can do many things but this is the most
common case yeah and we do it per type
so our query has the site field and so
it gets a function and it gives you the
the root is nothing in the query case
but the argument object for the second
one if your call site had it required a
name the site is the post field and if
you're caught if you recall it requires
a path but it also gives you the site as
the
root of that woke up field and the post
itself you know you get the post and
there are no fields on those lookups and
so using that post you have to look up
the authors and have to look up the tags
and in practice we do it like this you
know so this is the site looking up its
post and so nemesis TV is something
called a labeled edge but it just means
you can you know on the site store a
path and have it be a reference to
another object and we look it up and if
it doesn't exist we return null which is
perfectly allowed by the schema and then
we have and then if it does exist we go
only find it and we return that object
in fact we return a promise for that
object which is just fine post is a
little more complex but the author will
actually each one is even more simple
the author looks for an edge to a user
you know and if and it returns it you
know pulls out the ID and then actually
goes and gets the user same thing for
the tags except it's an array so we get
all the edges for the for the tags and
then we just sort of map over and get
each one return it and promise all and
so this each returns the object you're
looking for now if you have ever worked
and say rails the concept of n plus one
comes up all the time and this is when
you're making too many round trips to
the database and it slows everything
down and I it's really just not a
problem if you match the query of the
commands to match the queries right and
so data loader is a little utility it's
like a couple hundred lines and it lets
you take all the requests you make in
one once event loop and batch them all
together so you give it a little
function do the lookup and I made up a
function here get a bunch of IDs then
those how to look up like a whole array
of IDs and so you can go and ask for a
bunch of objects and then it's going to
call your your batch your bachelor your
get bunch of IDs with addy DuPage array
of all those things are trying to get
and this allows you to instead of having
if I load 50 posts and all their authors
instead of loading each other
individually it's going to go and give
me 50 IDs for those 50 authors so
instead of doing a new request and you
look up to the database for each item it
does it for each depth
the graph this made it much faster and
we were able to abuse this a little bit
and we're able to do it with with Redis
itself there's something called
pipelining which lets you put a whole
bunch of crazed together and no one
query and send them all and so if we
wanted to
this is nemesis DB again which can take
Redis object or can take your Redis
loader object which is the same shape
and if you go and you ask for all these
notes at the same time with Redis and
this is not a fair benchmark I ran out
on my own machine and localhost but it
will do four different queries and vote
with Redis loader it does one query with
with less because it doesn't ask for
node twice and it's significantly faster
when you added real network in there
maybe you need to multiply this by 10 or
100 but it's still real fast so even if
we didn't match I don't think I would
have noticed for our setup but for most
databases which maybe it's a couple
milliseconds between responses you know
it's a good idea to keep them together
and this keeps you protected I guess it
becomes from an N plus 1 2 and plus 1
divided by you know whatever is a
reasonable batch size 200 or something
like that the tooling we use to to put
to deploy our lambdas right now we're
using Sammy which uses Amazon Sam this
serverless application model under the
hood but Sam is kind of annoying uh I'm
sorry
Sam is kind of verbose and so we made a
little wrapper that helps you know
generate some useful scripts and so that
were you Sammy for most of our projects
I'm really excited about architect I
find out of our codes and it lets you
describe the kind of server this
environment you want
dynamodb tables there's a little
prescriptive but it's it's it's super
straightforward to use and I think it
makes getting started aflame just super
easy and of course we built a tool
called shop which I forgot to put in a
description but chef is the shepherd for
your lambdas
and chef is not prescriptive it just
sets up like like here's your functions
in a folder here's a web pack like
config that works and will will deploy
stuff and about a second or two and it's
a fastest way to get something out there
because it escapes CloudFormation and
all those other big things that if you
don't know about yet maybe get in the
way but it still works it's great we
just do we we've required more and it's
easier to go to Sam
or rather Sammy I think that's all you
need to get goin I think you could take
this and if you go to the repo I'd have
all the code there and you can choose
one of those deploy tools and you can
run your API on lambda today Redis
running Redis you know for Hobby project
is a little more expensive so you can
swap that out for anything you want like
literally anything you want
so DynamoDB or Postgres you know and it
will work the same way
nemesis isn't finished and you can
totally help and if you have opinions or
if you think we could achieve this with
a database that already exists you
should come and try to convince me of
that
because it would be awesome not to build
anything we have a ton of open-source
libraries that we use for our stuff
you'll you we just share them and
sometimes we sneak them into other
things but everything from the command
batching - you know officially storing
JSON documents of trees to working with
async iterators which I want to
completely replace all my streams with -
using async functions and streams with
blue stream which which is was our work
around before I think iterators was the
place you should check it out
love love any feedback and help and
hopefully it makes things working with
whatever you're doing somewhat easier
Thanks
you